am liebsten würde er wohl jetzt schon
ran zumal die wahl längst gelaufen ist
für joe biden und camilla harris doch
weil der andere die niederlage partout
nicht akzeptieren will
geht sie in die nächste runde der
erbitterte schlacht ums weiße haus
laut verfassung müsste er nur abwarten
denn spätestens am 20
januar ist game over verliert er sein
podium aber donald trump zeigt sich als
schlechter verlierer gibt seiner partei
die parole vor
wir wollen die wahl stehlen die wahl
fälschen das dürfen wir nicht zulassen
für so etwas hat er seine leute nicht
die besten anwälte des landes aber
seinen allerbesten und ganz persönlichen
anwalt dumm dass der versehentlich vor
einer gärtnerei die den gleichen namen
trägt wie das eigentlich geplante
nobel-hotel in den kampf zog bei four
seasons gartenbau rief rudy giuliani
wahlbetrug beweise blieb er schuldig der
präsident beginnt eine schuppen tat er
verhindert den übergang der macht
verstopft das system mit frivolen klagen
die gleich wieder raus fliegen wenn ein
richter sie sieht er schwächt das
vertrauen des amerikanischen volkes
nicht nur in die wahl sondern auch in
ihr ergebnis
tatsächlich liefen wahl und auszählung
betrugs frei wie selbst republikanischen
regierungen in den bundesstaaten
bestätigen die ergebnisse wurden unter
polizeischutz abgeliefert richter wiesen
bisher trumps klagen ab aus mangel an
beweisen und sogar george hw bush der
ehemalige präsident gratulierte joe
biden zum wahlsieg warum nicht auch die
anführer der republikanischen partei in
nibelungentreue stehen sie zu trump
wagen keinen widerspruch ein voran senat
mitch mcconnell
weil er des präsidenten hilfe braucht in
den vereinigten staaten müssen alle
legalen stimmen gezählt werden alle
illegalen stimmung nicht die
republikaner im senat brauchen den
präsidenten um ihre mehrheit zu
verteidigen bei stichwahlen in georgia
anfang jahr
solange trump über 70 millionen wähler
hinter sich weiß ist er der mächtigste
mann in der republikanischen partei und
bleibt es wohl auch wenn er sein amt
doch am ende räumen müsste er hat eine
menge macht aufgrund einer
republikanischen basis die ihm gehorsam
folgt die anführer der partei haben
angst davor weil sie sehen dass der
präsident mehr stimmen hat als 2016
er hat nicht an zustimmung verloren
sondern sogar dazu gewonnen deshalb
könnte auch so bayerns wichtigster satz
vom wochenende bei republikanern einfach
so verhalten die weigerung von
demokraten und republikanern
zusammenzuarbeiten ist kein
geheimnisvoller zwang den wir nicht
kontrollieren können sondern eine freie
entscheidung und es ist ein teil des
auftrags den uns das amerikanische volk
gibt es will dass wir zusammen arbeiten
und doch kann joe biden nichts von
donald trump erwarten nicht einmal den
respekt den ihm barack obama erwies mit
einer sorgfältigen übergaben das
republikaner trump das durchgehen lassen
empört zumindest einige
einer republikanischen partei die sich
so verhält will ich nicht mehr angehören
die abwehrfront der republikaner
blockiert die übergabe auch wenn beiden
eifrig weiter placht seinem expertenteam
für den kampf gegen korona verweigert
die trump administration den sonst
üblichen zugang ins
gesundheitsministerium und andere
regierungsbehörden während die zahl der
infektionen und todesfälle explodiert
wieder kühlcontainer vor den
leichenhäusern parken ruft donald trump
zum massenprotest auch am samstag sollen
seine fans und bewaffnete milizen in
washington dagegen protestieren dass ihm
die wahl angeblich gestohlen wird
ich fürchte dass es so weit treibt das
es unruhen geben wird dass er bei zisch
millionen amerikanern zweifel an der
legitimität der wahl führt wir haben uns
noch nicht hinter uns ist alles nur
politisches kalkül oder das endspiel
eines instabilen geistes willfährige
gefolgsleute und ein unberechenbarer
narzisstischer anführer seit jahren
warnen mehr als 100 psychologen vor der
gefahr die von donald trump ausgibt
seine anhängerschaft ist jetzt schon
ziemlich irrational wirklichkeitsfern
und darauf abgerichtet alle zu folgen
was er sagt das ist eine sehr
gefährliche situation wenn er das
wahlergebnis nicht unterlaufen kann gibt
es keine grenze für ihn dabei eine
wirklichkeit zu zerstören
die ihm nicht passt seine twitter
tiraden über 170 tweets und retweets
nach dem wahltag halten dr li und ihre
kolleginnen für symptomatisch
seinen justizminister lässt ramp nun
wegen angeblichen wahlbetrugs ermitteln
seinen verteidigungsminister hat der per
tweet gefeuert loyalisten im pentagon
installiert erfüllungsgehilfen für was
der verteidigungsminister war die
einzige person die ihn vom missbrauch
von nuklearwaffen oder seiner macht
kriege zu erklären abhalten konnte
letzte woche hat er schon drei der
spitzenleute in den behörden für
nuklearsicherheit gefeuert auch das ist
ein alarmsignal
wenn ihr einfach eine art von
kriegsrecht aus ruft dann hätten wir
eine ernste verfassungskrise in den
vereinigten staaten
er könnte befehle geben und diese leute
von ihm installiert gehorchen ihm direkt
ich glaube nicht dass so etwas geschieht
und ich hoffe dass ich da nicht falsch
liege aber sagt viel aus über die
psychologie und die psyche dieses mal
das schlimmste szenario scheint
übertrieben aber man traut ihm alles zu
die schlacht ums weiße haus geht weiter
vielleicht gar bis zum tag der
amtseinführung dem zwanzigster januar 20
21 aber trump und der tourismus werden
beiden auch danach begleiten und lauern
auf revanche
[Musik]